The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
So it has been a little
bit more than a week
when we met the last time.
Before I continue our
discussion of metrology
and interferometry.
I just want to share
something I saw on my visit
to the Netherlands.
When I visited the University of
Delft and the Kavli Institute,
they had just accomplished the
entanglement of two NV centers.
And we had just talked in
class about the entanglement
of two ions.
So I'm sort of
excited to show you
that people have just
taken the next step.
And what often the
next step means
is that in atomic physics, we
use pristine systems-- ions,
neutral atoms in
[INAUDIBLE] vacuum chamber.
And we create new
forms of entanglement.
Or with quantum gases, new
forms of quantum matter.
But ultimately, we hope that
those concepts, those methods,
and this knowledge
translates to some room
temperature materials or
solid state materials which
can be handled more
easily, and are therefore
much closer to applications.
So NV centers are kind of
nature's natural ion trap,
or nature's natural
neutral atom trap.
Let's not discuss whether
this is neutral or ionized.
It's a vacancy in nitrogen.
And it has a spectrum
which looks like an atom.
So you can say once you have
such a defect in nitrogen,
you have an atom, a single
atom in an atom trap
or an ion in an ion trap.
And you don't have
to create the vacuum.
It's there.
Every time you look
at it, it's there.
And you can excite
it with the laser.
It has a spectrum
similar to atoms.
It has spin
structure So you have
these vacancies in diamond.
So these are little
quantum dots.
But now you have two problems.
One is you want to collect
the light emitted by them.
And what is best is to mill a
lens right into the material.
So this is the diamond material.
A lens is milled.
And that already gives
some [? culmination ?]
of the light emitted by it.
But the bit problem
until recently
has been when you create
those some people call it
artificial atoms.
Every atom is a
little bit different,
because it experience a
slightly different environment.
A crystal has strain, so if you
have seemingly two identical
defects in a diamond
crystal, the two defects
will have a
resonance line, which
is a few gigahertz difference.
You would say, well, maybe
it's just [? apart ?] in 10
to the 5, but it means the
photons are distinguishable.
So if you want to do
entanglement by having two such
artificial atoms emitting a
photon onto a beam splitter,
and then by performing
a measurement we project
the atoms into Bell state-- I
hope you all remember what we
discussed for the trapped ions--
then you have to make sure that
fundamentally, those photons
cannot be distinguished.
And the trick here is that
they put on some electrodes.
And by adding an
electric field, they
can change the
relative frequency.
And therefore, within
the frequency uncertainty
given by Heisenberg's
Uncertainty Relation,
they can make the two
photons identical.
And when, let's say, experiment.
Well, you have two NV
centers, defects in diamond.
You can manipulate with
microwaves coherently the spin.
You need lasers for
initialization and readout.
But then closer to what
we want to discuss,
you need laser beams which
excite the NV center.
And then the two NV
centers emit photons.
And what you see now is exactly
what we discussed schematically
and in context of the ions,
that the two NV centers now
emit photons.
And by using polarization
tricks and the beam splitter,
you do a measurement
after the beam splitter.
And based on the outcome
of the measurement,
you have successfully
projected the two NV centers
into a [INAUDIBLE] state.
OK, good.
All right.
Let me just summarize what our
current discussion is about.
This section is called
Quantum Metrology.
It is a section where we want
to apply the concepts we have
learned to precision
measurements.
It's actually a chapter
which I find nice.
We're not really
introducing new concepts.
We're using concepts
previously introduced.
And now you see how
powerful those concepts
are, what they can be used for.
So we want to
discuss the precision
we can obtain in
quantum measurement.
We apply it here to an
atom in the interferometer,
to an optical interferometer.
We could also
discuss the precision
of spectroscopic measurements.
A lot of precision measurements
have many things in common.
So what we discuss here
is as a generic example
for precision measurement
that we send light
from our center interferometer.
Here is a phase shift.
And the question is,
how accurately can we
measure the phase shift when
we use n photons as a resource?
And of course, you
are all familiar
with the fundamental limit of
standard measurements, which
is short noise.
And sort of as a warm up in
our last class Wednesday,
week ago, I showed you that when
we use coherent states of light
at the input of
the interferometer,
we obtain the short noise.
Well, it may not be surprising,
because coherent light
is as close as possible, has
similar to classical light.
But then we discussed single
mode, single photon input.
And by using the formalism
of the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer, we've found that
the phase uncertainty is again
1 over square root n.
So then the question is, how can
we go to the Heisenberg limit,
where we have an uncertainty
in the phase of 1 over n?
And just as a reminder,
I find it very helpful.
I told you that you can always
envision if you have n photons
and you multiply it, put
the n photons together
by multiplying the
frequency by n,
then you have one photon
which [INAUDIBLE] with n times
the frequency.
And it's clear if you
do a measurement at n
times the frequency,
your precision in phase
is n times better.
So what we have to do is
we have to sort of put
the n photons together.
And then we can get a precision
of the measurement, which
is not square root n,
but n times better.
So this is what we
want to continue today.
This is the outline I gave
you in the last class.
If you have this
optical interferometer,
this Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
And if you use coherent
sets or single photons
as the input state, we
obtain the short noise.
Now we have to change something.
And we can change
the input state,
we can change the beam splitter,
or we can change the readout.
So we have to change something
where we entangle the n
photons, make sure in some sense
they act as one giant photons,
with either n times
the frequency,
but definitely with n times
the sensitivity to phase shift.
Any questions?
Good.
The first example, which
we pretty much covered
in the last class, was an
entangled state interferometer.
So instead of having the
Mach-Zehnder interferometer
as we had before, we have
sort of a Bell state creation
device.
Then we provide the phase shift.
And then we have a
Bell analysis device.
And I want to use here the
formalism and the symbols
we had introduced earlier.
So just as a reminder, what
we need is I need two gates.
One is the Hadamard gate,
which in matrix representation
has this matrix form.
And that means if you have
a qubit which is either up
or down and you apply
the matrix to it,
you put it in a superposition
state of up and down.
It's a single qubit rotation.
You can say for the bloch
on the Bloch sphere,
it's a 90 degree rotation.
The second gate we need
is the controlled NOT.
And the controlled NOT
we discussed previously
can be implemented by
having an interferometer
and using a non-linear Kerr
medium coupling another photon
to the interferometer
in such a way
that if you have a
photon in mode C,
it creates a phase shift
with the interferometer.
If there is no
photon in mode C, it
does not create an
additional phase shift.
And as we have
discussed, this can
implement the controlled NOT.
So these are the ingredients.
And at the end of
the last class,
I just showed you what those
quantum gates can do for us.
If you have two qubits at
the input, we apply the--
and I will assume they
are both in logical 0--
the Hadamard gate makes
the coherent superposition.
And then, we have
a controlled NOT
where this is the target gate.
Well, if this is 0, if
the control beat is 0,
the target beat stays 0.
So we get 0, 0.
If the control beat is 1, the
target beat is flipped to 1.
So we get 1, 1.
So the result is
that we have now
created a state 0, 0 plus 1, 1.
And if we apply a phase shift
to all the photons coming out
on the right hand side, we get
a phase shift which is too fine.
So we already get the idea.
If we take advantage
of a state 1, 1,
it has twice the [? face ?]
sensitivity as a single photon.
And we may therefore
get the full benefit
of the factor of 2, and
not just square root 2.
And this is what this
discussion is about.
Questions?
OK, so that's where we ended.
We can now use
another controlled NOT
and bring in the third qubit.
So what we create here.
Just make a reference, this
is where we start today.
So we create here the state,
which is either all beats
are 0, all beats are 1, and
then the phase shift gives us
three times the phase shift phi.
And therefore, by bringing
in more and more qubits,
I've shown you n equals
1, n equals 2, n equals 3.
So now you can go to n.
We obtain states which have n
times the phase sensitivity.
Let me just mention in
passing that for n equals 3,
the superposition of 0, 0, 0
and 1, 1, 1 goes by the name
not gigahertz, GHZ.
Greenberger.
This third one is Zeilinger.
The second one is--
AUDIENCE: Horne.
PROFESSOR: Horne.
Thank you.
Greenberger-Horne-Zeilinger
state.
And those states play
an important role
in test of Bell's inequality.
Or more generally, states which
are macroscopically distinct
are also regarded cat states
or Schrodinger cat states.
If we apply a phase
shift and go now
through the
entangler in reverse,
just a reverse sequence of
CNOT gates and Hadamard gates,
then we have all
the other n minus,
have the n minus 1 qubits.
All the qubits except
for the first reset to 0.
But the first qubit is now
in a superposition state
where we have the
phase into the power n.
And now, we can
make a measurement.
And P is now the probability
to find a single photon
in the first qubit.
So in other words,
our measurement
is exactly the same
as we had before where
we had the normal
Mach-Zehnder interferometer.
We put in one photon at a time.
And we determined
the probability.
What is the photon at one of the
outputs of the interferometer?
But the only
difference is that we
have now a factor of n in the
exponent for the phase shift.
And I want to show you what
is caused by this factor of n.
Let me first remind
you how we analyzed
the sensitivity of
an interferometer
for single photon input before.
So for a moment,
set n equals 1 now.
Then you get what we
discussed two weeks ago.
The probability is [INAUDIBLE]
as an interferometer.
Sine also, cosine also
infringes with cosine phi.
If you do measurements
with a probability P,
that's a binomial distribution.
Then the deviation
or the square root
of the variance in the binomial
distribution is P times 1
minus P. And by inserting p
here, we get sine phi over 2.
The derivative of P, which
is our signal, with a phase
is given by that.
And then just using
error propagation,
the uncertainty in the
phase is the uncertainty
in P divided by dp dt.
So then we repeat the
whole experiment n times,
and if your binomial
distribution and we
do m [INAUDIBLE] of our
[INAUDIBLE] with probability P,
we get an m under
the square root.
And then we get 1
over square root m.
And this was what I
showed you two weeks ago,
the standard short noise limit.
But now we have this
additional factor of n
here, which means that
our probability has
a cosine which goes with n phi.
When we take the derivative,
we get a factor of n here.
And then dp d phi
has the derivative.
But then we have to
use a chain rule, which
has another factor of n.
And therefore, we obtain now
that the phase sensitivity
goes as 1 over n.
And therefore, we reach
the Heisenberg limit.
So if you have now your n
photon entangler, the one I
just-- the entanglement
operation with these n cubits
is special beam spreader
replaced by the entangler,
we have now a sensitivity,
which goes 1 over n.
And then of course,
if you want, you
can repeat the
experiment n times.
And whenever you
repeat an experiment,
you gain an addition with
the square root of m.
Just give me one second.
We have this.
OK, so this is an example where
we had n qubits entangled,
like here.
And the sensitivity of
this interferometer scales
now as the Heisenberg
limit with 1 over n.
OK, I want to give you,
because they're all nice
and they're all special,
I want to give you
three more example how you can
reach the Heisenberg limit.
The next one goes by the name
super beam splitter method.
It's actually a very
fancy beam splitter
where you have two prods
of your beam splitter.
One has 0 and one has n photons.
And behind the beam splitter,
you have two options.
Either all the n photons
are in one state,
or the n photons are
in the other state.
You never have
any other mixture.
Of course, you know your
standard half silvered
mirror will not do that for
you, because it will split the n
photon state with some
Poissonian statistics
or whatnot into the
two arms and such.
And you can calculate
exactly what a normal beam
splitter does to that.
It's very, very different.
This here is a very, very
special beam splitter.
Just to demystify this
beam splitter a little bit,
I want to show you that, at
least conceptually, there
is an easy implementation
with atoms.
I really like in this section
to grab an example from atoms
and to grab an example for
photons, because it really
brings out that the
language may develop equally
applies to atoms and photon.
So if I take now
an easy example,
if I take an example of the
Bose-Einstein condensate with n
atoms, let's assume
we have a double well.
But now we have
attractive interactions.
This is not your standard BEC.
Your standard
Bose-Einstein condensate
has repulsive interaction,
with attractive interaction.
If you go beyond a certain
size, certain a atom number,
the condensate will collapse.
So let's assume we have a
Bose-Einstein condensate with n
atoms.
There are some
attractive interactions,
but we stay within
the stability diagram
that those atoms do not-- that
those atoms do not collapse.
So now, if the atoms
are attractive,
they all want to be together.
Because then they lower
the energy of each other.
So if you have something
with attractive interaction,
you want to have
n atoms together.
But if your double
well potential
is absolutely symmetric,
there is no symmetry breaking,
and you have an equal
amplitude for all the atoms
to be in the other well.
So therefore, under the
very idealized situation
I described here,
you will actually
create a superposition
state of n atoms
in one well with n
atoms in the other well.
And this is exactly
what we tried
to accomplish with
this beam splitter.
OK, so if we have this
special beam splitter, which
creates that state,
then when we add a phase
shift to one arm of
the interferometer,
we obtain-- which looks very
promising-- a phase shift
phi multiplied by n.
And if we read it
out, we have now
if you pass it through the
other super beam splitter,
we create again a
superposition of n0 and 0n.
But now, because
of the phase shift
with cosine and sine factors,
which involve n times
the phase shift.
For obvious reasons,
those states
also go by the name noon states.
That's the name which everybody
uses for those states,
because if you just read
n00n, it gives noon.
So this is the
famous noon state.
So it seems it smells
already, right,
because it has a
phase shift of n phi.
Let me just convince you
that this is indeed the case.
So the probability
of reading out
0 photons in one arm
of the interferometer
scales now with
the cosine square.
If you do one
single measurement,
the binomial
distribution is the same
as before, but
with a factor of n.
The derivative has
those factors of n.
And that means that the variance
in the phase measurement
is now 1 over n.
If you want a reference,
I put it down here.
As far as I know,
the experiment has
been done with three
photons, but not
with larger photon number.
Questions?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: This picture
with the double well,
isn't there going to be-- all
right, some people would say
you spontaneously break the
symmetry and [INAUDIBLE]
either ends up in one
side or the other.
Like isn't this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
Bose-Einstein condensation
with attractive interactions
was observed in 1995.
And now, 18 years later, nobody
has done this seemingly simple
experiment.
And what happens
is really that you
have to be very,
very careful against
any experimental imperfection.
If the two double well
potentials are not
exactly identical,
the bosons always
want to go to the
lowest quantum state.
Well, that's their
job, so to speak.
That's their job description.
And if you have a
minuscule difference
between the two, the
dates of the two wells,
you will not get a
superposition state.
You will simply
populate one state.
And how to make it
experimentally [INAUDIBLE],
this is a really big challenge.
[? Tino ?].
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Let's say we're somehow
able to make the double well
potential perfect.
But if we didn't have
attractive interactions,
then wouldn't he just
get a big product state
of each atom being
in either well?
PROFESSOR: OK, if you're
a non-interacting system,
the ground state of a
double well potential
is just your metric state 1
plus 2 over square root 2.
And for non-interactive
BEC, you figure out
what is the ground
state for one particle
and then take it to the power n.
This is the non-interactive BEC.
STUDENT: So then entanglement
is because of the interaction,
right?
PROFESSOR: If you have
strong repulsive interaction,
you have something
which should remind you
of the [INAUDIBLE] insulator.
You have n atoms.
And n over 2 atoms go
to one well. n over 2 go
to the other well.
Because any form of number
fluctuations would be costly.
It will cost you additional
repulsive interaction.
So therefore, the
condensate wants
to break up into
two equal parts.
So that's actually
a way how you would
create another non-classical
state, the dual flux
state of n over 2,
n over 2 particle.
And for attractive
interactions, well you
should create the known state.
OK, so this was now
a state n0 and 0n.
There is another
state, which you
have encountered
in your homework.
And this is a superposition
not of n0 and 0n and n0.
It's a superposition of n
minus 1n and n n minus 1.
This state goes by the person
I think who invented it,
the [? Yerkey ?] state.
And you showed in your homework
that with that, you also
reach Heisenberg Limited
Interferometry, where
the phase scales is 1 over n.
What I want to add
here to it is how
one can create such
a [? Yerkey ?] state.
And again, I want
to use the example
with an atomic
Bose-Einstein condensate.
And here's the reference where
this was very nicely discussed.
So let's assume we can create
two Bose-Einstein condensates.
And they have exactly n atoms.
And I would actually refer
to [? Tino's ?] questions how
to make them have
two n atoms in a trap
and then make a
double well potential,
deform the harmonic oscillator
potential to a double well
potential.
Then for strong
repulsive interactions,
the condensate
will symmetrically
split into two flux states,
each of which has n atoms.
So now how can we create the
[? Yerkey ?] state from that?
Well, we simply have--
we leak out atoms.
We leak atoms out of the trap.
My group demonstrated an RF
beam splitter, how you can just
split in very
controlled way start
rotating the cloud
on non-trapped state.
And then atoms slowly leak out.
Well, when you can
measure, of course,
you can take an atom
detector and measure
that an atom has
been out-coupled,
leaked out of the trap.
If you don't like
RF rotation, you
can also think that there
is a tunneling barrier,
and atoms slowly leak out
by whatever mechanism.
And the moment you
detect that an atom,
you then project the state in
the trap to n minus 1 atom,
because you've measured
that one atom has come out.
But now you use a beam splitter.
And a beam splitter could
simply be a focused laser beam.
And the atoms have
a 50% probability
of being reflected or
end up tunneling through.
So therefore, if you
have now a detector
which measures the
atoms on one side
and the atoms on the
other side, then you
don't know anymore when the
detector makes click form which
atom trap the atom came.
Or more formally,
a beam splitter
transforms the two input modes
ab into a plus b and a minus b
normalized by square root 2.
So therefore, if
this detector clicks,
when you project the remaining
atoms into the symmetric state,
here you detect one atom
in the mode a plus b.
And that means that
the remaining atoms
have been projected into
the [? Yerkey ?] state.
If the lower atom
detector would click,
well, you get a minus sign here.
So that's one way how at
least in a conceptually simple
situation, you can prepare
this highly non-classical state
by starting with
a dual flux state
of Bose-Einstein
condensates, and then using--
and this is an ongoing theme
here-- by using a measurement,
and then the
post-measurement state is
the non-classical state
you wanted to prepare.
Question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How can you
ensure that only one
atom leaves the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The idea
is that we leak atoms
out very, very slowly.
And then we have
a detector, which
we assume has 100%
quantum efficiency.
So therefore, we simply wait
until the detector tells us
that one atom has leaked out.
And in an idealized experiment,
we know the atoms either
have been measured
by the detector,
or they are still in the trap.
AUDIENCE: And also,
is there a property
that holds the [INAUDIBLE]
you detect atoms [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: In principle
yes, but the idea here
is if you have a very
slow leakage process,
the probability that you detect
two atoms at the same time
is really zero.
You leak them continuously
and slowly, but then
quantum mechanically, that
means for most of the time,
you measure nothing.
That means the leakage
hasn't taken place.
The quantum mechanical
system has not developed yet.
But the moment you
perform a measurement,
you project-- it's
really the same
if you say you have
n radioactive atoms.
You have a detector.
And when the
detector makes click,
you know you have n minus
1 radioactive atoms left.
It's just applied here
to two atom types.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
And maybe I'll tell
you now why not.
We have discussed
the noon state.
And we have discussed here
a highly non-classical
superposition state.
Let's just go back
to the noon state.
We have n atoms here, zero here,
or n atoms, or the reverse.
But now, assume a single atom
is lost, is lost from your trap
by some background
gas collisions.
And you have surrounded
the trap with a detector.
So if you have the noon state,
the symmetric superposition
state, all atoms here
and all atoms there.
But by your background process,
by an inelastic collision,
you lose one atom.
And you detect it.
You could set up your
detectors that you
know from which
that you figure out
from which trap was
the particle lost.
So therefore, a
single particle lost
if you localize from which
trap the particle is lost
would immediately project
the noon state into a state
where you know I have n or
n minus 1 atoms in one well,
and 0 in the other well.
So I've already told
you, with the attenuator,
you can never assume
an attenuator is just
attenuating a beam.
An attenuator can always
regard it as a beam splitter.
And you can do measurements at
both arms of the beam splitter.
Or you have to consider
the vacuum noise which
enters through the other
part of the beam splitter.
And if you are now add that
those atoms, n atoms, in a trap
have some natural loss
by inelastic collision
or background gas
scattering, the loss
is actually like a beam
splitter that particles
don't stay in the trap, but
go out through the other part.
And then you can measure it.
So in other words,
every loss process
should be regarded as
a possible measurement.
And it doesn't
matter whether you
perform the measurement or not.
And I think it's just obvious
that the noon state, the moment
one particle is lost and you
reduce this particle to figure
out if n particles are here
or n particles are there,
the whole superposition
state is lost if you just
lose one single atom out of n.
So the lifetime of a noon state
is then not your usual trap
lifetime, where you
lose half of the atoms,
1 over e of the atoms.
It is n times faster because
it is the first atom lost,
which is already
completely removing
the entanglement of your state.
So more quantitatively, to
say it more specifically,
the limitation is loss.
When you have a fully entangled
state, maximally entangled
state, usually a
loss of one particle
immediately removes
the entanglement.
We had the situa-- no,
that's not a good example.
But for the most
entangled state,
usually-- and for
the noon state,
it's trivial to see-- a
single particle lost allows
you to measure on which side
of the potential barrier
all the atoms are,
and all the beauty
of the non-classical
state is lost.
So if you assume that
in a time window,
you have an infinitesimal
loss, a loss
of epsilon, what
usually happens is
if you have an entanglement
of n particles,
then you lose your entanglement.
If you expand 1
minus epsilon to n,
it becomes 1 minus
n times epsilon.
So that's one reason why
people have not scaled up
those schemes to a
large number of photons,
or a large number of atoms.
Because the larger n
is, the more sensitive
you are to even very,
very small losses.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or is that physically?
PROFESSOR: The
super beam splitter
would create the noon state.
I've not explained to
you what it physically
would be for photons,
but I gave you
the example for atoms
to BECs in a double well
potential with
attractive interaction.
So to start with
the condensate in--
AUDIENCE: Start with
a bigger [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you start with
a double well potential,
and you put in n
atoms initially in,
but then you switch
on tunnel coupling,
then you would
create the noon state
if the interactions
are attractive,
and if everything is idealized,
that you have a completely
symmetric double well potential.
OK, the last example is the
squeeze light Interferometer.
I just want to
mention it briefly,
because we've talked so
much about squeezed light.
So now I want to show you
that squeezed light can also
be used to realize Heisenberg
Limited Interferometery.
So the idea is, when we plot
the electric field versus time,
and if you do squeezing
in one quadrature,
then for certain times,
the electric field
has lower noise
and higher noise.
We discussed that.
And the idea is that if there is
no noise at the zero crossing,
that this means we can determine
the zero crossing of the light,
and therefore the phase
shift with higher accuracy.
You may also argue if you
have this quasi-probabilities,
and with squeezing, we have
squeezed the coherent light
into an ellipse.
And things propagate
with e to the i omega t.
Then you can determine
a phase shift,
which is sort of an angular
sector in this diagram,
with higher precision
if you have squeezed
this circle into an
ellipse like that.
So that's the idea.
And well, it's fairly clear that
squeezing, if done correctly,
can provide a better
phase measurement.
And what I want to show
you here in a few minutes
is how you can think about it.
So we have discussed at length
the optical Interferometer,
where we have just a
coherence state at the input.
This is your standard
laser Interferometer.
But of course, very importantly,
the second input port
has the vacuum state.
And we discussed the
importance of that.
So the one difference
we want to do now
is that we replace the
vacuum at the second input
by the squeezed
vacuum where r is
the parameter of
the squeezed vacuum.
OK, so that's pretty
much what we do.
We take this state, we
plug it into our equation,
we use exactly
the same formalism
we have used for
coherence states.
And the question,
what is the result?
Well, the result will be that
the squeezing factor appears.
Just as a reminder,
for our Interferometer,
we derived the sensitivity
of the Interferometer.
We had the quantities x and y.
And the noise is delta in this
y operator squared divided by x.
This was the result when we
operate the Interferometer
at the phase shift
of 90 degrees.
Just a reminder.
That's what we have done.
That's how we
analyze the situation
with a coherent state.
The signal x is
now-- the signal x
is the number
measurement a dagger a.
And we have now the input
of the coherent state.
And b dagger b.
We have an input
mode a and a mode b.
They get split.
And then we measure
it at the output.
And we can now at the
output have photons--
a dagger a, which come
from the coherent state,
and b dagger b, which come
from the squeeze vacuum.
So this is now using the
beam splitter formalism
applied to the Interferometer.
So this is now the
result we obtain.
And in the strong local
oscillator approximation,
it is only the first
part which contributes.
And this is simply the number
or photons in the coherent beam.
The expectation value
of y is 0, because it
involves a b and
b dagger operator.
And the squeezed
vacuum has only,
if you write it down, in the
n basis, in the flux basis,
has only even n.
So if you change
n by one, you lose
overlap with the
squeezed vacuum.
So therefore, this
expectation value is 0.
For the operator y squared,
you take this and square it.
And you get many, many terms,
which I don't want to discuss.
I use the strong
local oscillator.
Limited a dagger and
a can be replaced
by the eigenvalue alpha
of the coherent state.
So therefore, I factor
out alpha squared
in the strong local
oscillator limit.
And then what is left is
b plus b dagger squared.
And since we have
squeezed the vacuum,
this gives us a factor
into the minus r.
So if we put all those
results together,
we find that the phase
uncertainty is now
what we obtained when
we had a coherent state
with the ordinary vacuum.
And in the strong
local oscillator limit,
the only difference
to the ordinary vacuum
is that in this term, we've
got the exponential factor e
to the minus r.
And since we have
taken a square root,
it's e to the minus r over 2.
So that result would
actually suggest
that the more we squeeze,
that delta phi should go to 0.
So it seems even better
than the Heisenberg limit.
However-- well, this is
too good to be true--
what I've neglected here
is just the following.
When you squeeze more
and more, the more you
squeeze the vacuum,
the more photons
are in the squeezed vacuum,
because this ellipse stitches
further and further out and
has overlap with flux states
at higher and higher
photon number.
So therefore, when you go to
the limit of infinite squeezing,
you squeeze out
of the limit where
you can regard the local
oscillator as strong,
because the squeezed
vacuum has more photons
than your local oscillator.
And then you have to
consider additional terms.
So let me just write that down.
However, the squeezed vacuum has
non-zero average photon number.
And the photon number
of the squeezed vacuum
is, of course, apply b dagger
b to the squeezed vacuum.
This gives us a sinc function.
And we can call this
the number of photons
in the squeezed vacuum.
So we have to consider now
this contribution to y square.
So we have to
consider the quadrator
of the ellipse, the long
part of the ellipse,
the non-squeezed
quadrator component.
And we have to
consider that when
we calculate the expectation
value of y square.
And then we find
additional terms,
which I don't want
to derive here.
And the question is then, if
you squeeze too much, you lose.
So there's an optimal
amount of squeezing.
And for this optimal
amount of squeezing,
the phase uncertainty
becomes approximately one
over the number of photons
in the coherent state,
plus the number of photons
in your squeeze vacuum.
So this is, again, very close
to the Heisenberg limit.
So the situation
with squeezed light
is less elegant, because
if you squeeze too much,
you have to consider
additional terms.
This is why I gave you the
example of the squeezed light
and the squeezed
vacuum as the last.
But again, the Heisenberg
limit is very fundamental
as we discussed.
And for an optimum
arrangement of the squeezing,
you can also use a
squeezed vacuum input
to the Interferometer to
realize the Heisenberg limit.
Any questions?
Why is squeezing important?
Well, squeezing caught the
attention of the physics
community when it was
suggested in connection
with gravitational--
with the detection
of gravitational waves.
As you know, the
laser Interferometer,
the most advanced one is
LIGO, has a monumental task
in detecting a
very small signal.
And pretty much everything which
precision metrology can provide
is being implemented
for that purpose.
So you can see, this is
like precision measurement.
Like maybe the trip
to the moon was
for aviation in
several decades ago.
So everything is really--
a lot of things pushing
the frontier of
precision measurement
is motivated by the precision
needed for gravitational wave
detection.
And what I want to show
you here is a diagram
for what is called
advanced LIGO.
LIGO is currently
operating, but there
is an upgrade to LIGO
called advanced LIGO.
And what you
recognize here is we
have a laser which goes into
a Michelson Interferometer.
And this is how you want to
detect gravitational waves.
But now you realize
that the addition here
is a squeezed source.
And what you are
squeezing is not,
while it should be
clear to you now,
we're not squeezing
the laser beam.
This would be much, much harder,
because many, many photons are
involved.
But it is sufficient to
squeeze the vacuum and couple
in squeezed vacuum into your
cavitational wave detector.
If you wonder, it's a
little bit more complicated
because people want to
recycle light and have
put in other bells and whistles.
But in essence, a
squeezed vacuum source
is a major addition
to advanced LIGO.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where is
the squeeze actually
coming into the system?
I see where it's drawn,
but where is it actually
entering the interferometer?
At that first beam splitter?
PROFESSOR: OK.
We have to now-- there are
more things added here.
Ideally, you would think you
have a beam splitter here,
the laser comes in
here, and you simply
want to enter the
squeezed vacuum here.
And this is how we
have explained it.
We have one beam splitter
in our Interferometer.
There is an input
port and an open port.
But what is important
here is also
that the measurement--
here you have
a detector for reading
out the Interferometer.
And what is important
is that the phase
is balanced close to the point
where no light is coming out.
So you're measuring the
zero crossing of a fringe.
But that would mean
most of the light
would then exit
the Interferometer
at the other port.
But high power lasers are
very important for keeping
the classical short noise down.
So you want to work with
the highest power possible.
And therefore, you can't
allow the light to exit.
You want to recycle it.
You want to use
enhancement cavities.
And what I can tell you is that
this set up here integrates,
I think, the signal
recycling, the measurement
at the zero fringe.
And you see that kind
of those different parts
are copied in a
way which I didn't
prepare to explain it to you.
All I wanted you to
do is pretty much
recognize that a squeeze
light generator is important.
And this enters
the interferometer
as a squeezed vacuum.
What I find very
interesting, and this
is what I want to
discuss now is,
that when you have an
interferometer like LIGO,
cavitational wave
interferometer,
and now you want to squeeze.
Does it really help to squeeze?
Does it always help to squeeze?
Or what is the situation?
And this is what I want
to discuss with you.
So let's forget about signal
recycling and enhancement
cavities and things like this.
Let's just discuss the basic
cavitation wave detector, where
we have an input,
we have the two arms
of the Michelson interferometer.
And to have more
sensitivity, the light
bounces back and forth
in an enhancement cavity.
You can say if the light bounces
back and forth 100 times,
it is as if you had
an arm length which
is 100 times larger.
And now we put in
squeezed vacuum
at the open part of
the interferometer.
And here we have
our photo-diodes
to perform the measurement.
So the goal is to measure
a small length scale.
If a cavitation wave comes
by, cavitational waves
have quadrupolar character.
So the metric will
be such that there's
a quadrupolar perturbation
in the metric of space.
And that means that, in
essence, one of the mirrors
is slightly moving out.
The other mirror is
slightly moving in.
So therefore, the interferometer
needs a very, very high
sensitivity to displacement
of one of the mirrors
by an amount delta z.
And if you normalize
delta z to the arm length,
or the arm length times
the number of bounces,
the task is to
measure sensitivity
in a length displacement
of 10 to the minus 21.
That's one of the
smallest numbers
which have ever been measured.
And therefore, it is clear
that this interferometer
should operate as close
as possible to the quantum
limit of measurement.
So what you want to measure here
is, with the highest accuracy
possible, the displacement
of an object delta z.
However, your object fulfills
and uncertainty relationship,
that if you want to measure
the position very accurately,
you also have to consider that
it has a momentum uncertainty.
And this fulfills Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation.
You will say, well, why should
I care about the momentum
uncertainty if all I want
to measure is the position.
Well, you should care
because momentum uncertainty
after a time tau turns
into position uncertainty,
because position uncertainty
is uncertainty in velocity.
And if I multiply
it by the time tau
it takes you to perform
the measurement,
you have now an
uncertainty in position,
which comes from the original
uncertainty in momentum.
So if I use the expression
for Heisenberg's Uncertainty
Relation, I find this.
And now, what we
have to minimize
to get the highest precision
is the total uncertainty
in position, which is
the original uncertainty,
plus the uncertainty due
to the motion of the mirror
during the measurement process.
So what we have here
is we have delta z.
We have a contribution which
scores as 1 over delta z.
And by just finding out what is
the optimum choice of delta z,
you find the result above.
Or if you want to say you
want that this delta z tau is
comparable to delta z, just
set this equal to delta z,
solve for delta z, and
you find the quantum limit
for the interferometer,
which is given up there.
So this has nothing
to do with squeezing.
And you cannot improve on this
quantum limit by squeezing.
This is what you got.
It only depends on the
duration of the measurement.
And it depends on the
mass of the mirror.
Now-- just get my
notes ready-- there
is a very influential
and seminal paper
by Caves-- the reference
is given here--
which was really
laying out the concepts
and the theory for quantum
limited measurements with such
an interferometer, and
the use of squeezed light.
Let me just summarize the
most important findings.
So this paper explains that
you have two contributions
to the noise, which
depend on the laser
power you use for
your measurement.
The first one is the
photon counting noise.
If you use more and
more laser power,
you have a better
and better signal,
and your short noise is reduced.
So therefore, you have a better
read out of the interferometer.
And this is given here.
Alpha is the eigenvalue
of the coherent state.
But there is a second
aspect which you may not
have thought about it,
and this is the following.
If you split a laser
beam into two parts,
you have fluctuations.
The number of photons left
and right are not identical.
You have a coherent
bean and you split it
into two coherent
beams, and then you
have Poissonian
fluctuations on either side.
But if you have now Poissonian
fluctuations in the photon
number, if those photons
are reflected off a mirror,
they transfer photon
recoil to the mirror.
And the mirror is pushed
by the radiation pressure.
And it's pushed,
and it has-- there
is a differential motion
of the two mirrors
relative to each other due to
the fluctuations in the photon
number in the two arms
of the interferometer.
So therefore, what happens is
you have a delta z deviation
or variance in the measurement
of the mirror, which
comes from radiation pressure.
It's a differential radiation
pressure between the two arms.
And what Caves
showed in this paper
is that the two effects
which contribute
to the precision
of the measurement
come from two different
quadrature component.
For the photon
counting, we always
want to squeeze the
light in such a way
that we have the narrow
part of the ellipse
in the quadrature component
of our coherent beam.
We've discussed
it several times.
So therefore, you want to
squeeze it by e to the minus r.
However, when what has a good
effect for the photon counting
has a bad effect
for the fluctuations
due to radiation pressure.
So therefore, what
happens is-- let's
forget squeezing for a moment.
If you have two contributions,
one goes to the noise,
one goes with alpha squared
of the number of photons.
One goes inverse with the square
root of the number of photons.
You will find out that
even in the interferometer
without squeezing, there
is an optimum laser
power, which you want to use.
Because if you use
two lower power,
you lose in photon counting.
If you use two higher
power, you lose
in the fluctuations of
the radiation pressure.
So even without squeezing,
there is an optimum laser power.
And for typical parameters,
so there is an optimum power.
And what we're
shown in this paper
is whenever you choose
the optimum power which
keeps a balance between
photon counting and radiation
pressure, then you reach
the standard quantum
limit of your interferometer.
But it turns out that
for typical parameters,
this optimum is 8,000 watt.
So that's why
people at LIGO work
harder and harder to develop
more and more powerful
lasers, because more
laser power brings
them closer and closer
to the optimum power.
But once they had
the optimum power,
additional squeezing
will not help them
because they are already at
the fundamental quantum limit.
So the one thing which
squeezing does for you, it
changes the optimum
power in your input beam
by a squeezing factor.
So therefore, if you
have lasers which
have maybe 100 watt
and not 8,000 watt,
then squeezing helps you to
reach the fundamental quantum
limit of your interferometer.
So that's pretty
much all I wanted
to say about precision
measurements.
I hope the last example--
it's too complex to go
through the whole analysis--
but it gives you at least a
feel that you have
to keep your eye
on both quadrature components.
You can squeeze, you
can get an improvement,
in one physical
effect, but you have
to be careful to consider what
happens in the other quadrature
component.
And in the end, you have to
keep the two of them balanced.
Any questions?
Oops.
OK.
Well, we can get started with
a very short chapter, which
is about g2.
The g2 measurement
for light and atoms.
I don't think you will
find the discussion I
want to present to
you in any textbook.
It is about whether g2 is 1 or
2, whether we have fluctuations
or not.
And the discussion will be
whether g2 of 2 and g2 of 1
are quantum effect
or classical effects.
So I want to give you
here in this discussion
four different derivations of
whether g2 is 1 or g2 is 2.
And they look very,
very different.
Some are based on
classical physics.
Some are based on the
concept of interference.
And some are based on the
quantum indistinguishability
of particles.
And once you see you all those
four different explanations,
I think you'll see
the whole picture.
And I hope you
understand something.
So again, it's a long
story about factors of 2.
But there are some factors of 2
which are purely calculational,
and there are other
factors of 2 which
involve a hell of
a lot of physics.
I mean, there are people
who say the g2 factor of 2
is really the difference between
ordinary light and laser light.
For light from a
light bulb, g2 is 2.
For light from a laser, g2 is 1.
And this is the only
fundamental difference
between laser light
and ordinary light.
So this factor of
2 is important.
And I want to therefore have
this additional discussion
of the g2 function.
So let me remind
you that g2 of 0
is the normalized probability
to detect two photons or two
particles simultaneously.
And so far, we have
discussed it for light.
And the result we obtained by
using our quantum formulation
of light with creation
annihilation operator,
we found that g2 is 0.
In the situation that we had
black body radiation, which
we can call thermal
light, it's sometimes
goes by the name chaotic light.
Sometimes it's called
classical light,
but that may be a misnomer,
because I regard the laser
beam as a very
classical form of light.
This is sometimes
called bunching
because 2 is larger than 1.
So pairs of photons
appear bunched up.
You have a higher probability
than you would naively
expect of detecting two
photons simultaneously.
And then we had the situation of
laser light and coherent light
where the g2 function was 1.
And I want to shed some
light on those two cases.
We have discussed the extreme
case of a single photon
where the probability
of detecting two photons
is 0 for trivial reasons.
So you have a g2 function of 0.
But this is not what I
want to discuss here.
I want to shed some
light on when do we
get a g2 function of 1.
When do we get a
g2 function of 2.
And one question
we want to address,
when we have a g2
function of 2, is
this a classical
or quantum effect?
Do you have an opinion?
Who thinks-- question.
AUDIENCE: When we did the
homework problem where
we had the linear's
position, like alpha
minus alpha
[INAUDIBLE] plus alpha,
we found that one can
have a g2 greater than 1,
and one can have
a g2 less than 1.
So maybe g2 isn't a
great discriminator,
whether it's very
quantum or very classic.
PROFESSOR: Let's hold
this thought, yeah.
You may be right.
Let's come back to that.
I think that's one opinion.
The g2 function may
not be a discriminator,
because we can have g2 of 1
and g2 of 2 purely classical.
But why classical light
behaves classically,
maybe that's what we
can understand there.
And maybe what I
want to tell you
is that a lot of classical
properties of classical light
can be traced down to the
indistinguishability of bosons,
which are photons.
So in other words, we
shouldn't be surprised
that something which
seems purely classical
is deeply rooted
in quantum physics.
But I'm ahead of my agenda.
So let me start now.
I want to offer you
four different views.
And the first one is that
we have random intensity
fluctuations.
Think of a classical
light source.
And we assume that if
things are really random,
they are described by a
Gaussian distribution.
And if you switch on
a light bulb, what
you get if you measure the
intensity when you measure what
is the probability that the
momentary intensity is I,
well, you have to normalize
it to the average intensity.
But what you get is pretty much
an exponential distribution.
And this exponential
distribution
has a maximum at I equals 0.
So the most probable
intensity of all intensities
when you switch
on a light bulb is
that you have 0 intensity
at a given moment.
But the average
intensity is I average.
So you can easily, for
such a distribution,
for such an exponential
distribution,
figure out what is the
average of I to the power n.
It is related to I
average to the power n,
but it has an n factorial.
And what is important is the
case for our discussion of n
equals 2, where the
square of the intensity
averaged is two times the
average intensity squared.
And classically, g2
is the probability
of detecting two
photons simultaneously,
which is proportional
to I square.
We have to normalize it.
And we normalize it
by I average square.
And this gives 2.
So simply light with
Gaussian fluctuations
would give rise to
a g2 function of 2.
Since it's random fluctuations,
it's also called chaotic light.
And the physical pictures
is the following.
If you detect a photon,
the light is fluctuating.
But whenever you detect
the first photon,
it is more probable that you
detect take the first photon
when the intensity
happened to be high.
And then since the
intensity is high,
the probability
for the next photon
is higher than the
average probability.
So therefore, you get
necessarily a g2 function of 2.
So this is the physics of it.
So let me just write that down.
The first photon is more
likely to be detected
when the intensity
fluctuation-- when
intensity fluctuations
give high intensity.
And then we get this result.
Yes.
Let us discuss a second
classical view, which
I can call wave interference.
This is really important.
A lot of people get
confused about it.
If you have light
in only one mode,
this would be the
laser of, for atoms,
the Bose-Einstein condensate.
One mode means a single wave.
So if we have plain waves, we
can describe all the photons
or all the atoms by
this wave function.
So what is the g2 function
for an object like this?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: Trivially
1, because if something
is a clean wave, a single
wave, all correlation functions
factorize.
You have the situation that
I to the power n average
is I average to the power n.
And that means that
gn is 1 for all n.
OK, but let's now
assume that we have two.
We can also use more, but
I want to restrict to two.
That we have only two modes.
And two modes can interfere.
So let me apply to those
two modes a simple model.
And whether it's simple
or not is relative.
So it goes like as follows.
If you have two modes,
both of Unity intensity,
then the average intensity is 2.
But if you have interference,
then the normalized intensity
will vary between 0 and 4.
Constructive interference
means you get twice as much
as average.
Destructive means
you get nothing.
So therefore, the
[? nt ?] squared
will vary between 0 and 16.
So if I just use the two
extremes, it works out well.
You have an I
square, which is 8,
the average of
constructive interference
and destructive interference.
And this is two times
the average intensity,
which is 2 squared.
So therefore, if you
simply allow fluctuations
due to the interference
of two modes,
we find that the
g2 function is 2.
So this demonstrates
that g2 of 2
has its deep origin
in wave interference.
And indeed, if you take a
light bulb which emits photons,
you have many, many atoms
in your tungsten filament
which can emit, re-emit waves.
And since they have
different positions,
the waves arrive at your
detector with random phases.
And if you really write
that down in a model--
this is nicely done in
the book by Loudon--
you realize that
random interference
between waves results in
an exponential distribution
of intensity.
So most people wouldn't
make the connection.
But there is a deep and
fundamental relationship
between random interference and
the most random distribution,
the exponential
distribution, intensity
which characterises thermal
light or chaotic light.
So let me just write that down.
So the Gaussian intensity
distribution-- actually
it's an exponential
intensity distribution.
But if you write the
intensity distribution
as a distribution in
the electric field,
intensity becomes e square.
Then it becomes a
Gaussian [INAUDIBLE].
So Gaussian or exponential
intensity distribution
in view number one is the
result, is indeed the result,
of interference.
Any questions?
So these are the
two classical views.
I think we should stop now.
But on Wednesday, I will present
you alternative derivations,
which are completely
focused on quantum operators
and quantum counting statistics.
Just a reminder, we have
class today and Friday.
And we have class
this week on Friday.